do you ever think about all of the
produce in the grocery store that never
finds a home well it's really sad sorry
let me explain I used to work in the
produce section of a grocery school and
we were instructed to walk around and
extract all of this sad imperfect ugly
protic just get it out of sight but it's
okay because we made a big meal and all
that ugly food just Kenny it all gets
thrown out just for being unpleasant to
looking which brings us to tears right
now this second I'm gonna go to the
grocery store and I'm gonna rescue one
fruit or vegetable just give it the
treatment it deserves I'm gonna give up
the food a makeover so as I head to the
store I truthfully have absolutely no
idea what I'm gonna find now this could
be an awful looking an asparagus it
could be a hideous Apple but what I do
know is that the end of this is
something that was previously unwanted
will be transformed into something
beautiful and delicious
[Music]
three-two-one Oh is uglier than I
remember
you deserve a closer look so what we
have here is a pair and as you can see
it's pretty pretty hurt bulbous isn't a
word I use very often but I think it's
fair in this case truthfully this video
isn't about shaming something that's
different looking if anything I think
it's more about unlocking the potential
that lives within this pair before I
jump onto the computer to figure out
what I'm gonna do with this pair I want
to get some more pairs of eyes on this
pair just to confirm that this pair is a
mess yeah
is that a pair this is the pair of no
one would have bought today at the store
you can make this so cute if you turn
this into the thing that smokes in Alice
in Wonderland do you know what I'm
talking about the caterpillar doesn't it
look this is exactly what the are you
still talking I'm just in awe am I
thinking about the right animal okay so
the next time you see this pair it's
gonna be beautiful and delicious are you
taking my idea turning into a chatter
yeah No
so there does seem to be a consensus
that the pair is less than ideal looking
so it's time for research I know what
I'm gonna do to give this pair a
makeover I'm gonna poach it everybody's
still good over here okay we're gonna
mix a lot of these nice ingredients
together in a pod bring it to a little
simmer action you're I was all ready to
just leap into this recipe didn't wash
the pear some simple syrup here wine
[Music]
[Music]
and amend sticks get everyone see how
those cinnamon sticks are put in here
they are placed in there so well okay it
says to break the cinnamon stick in half
and going to the gym recently as you can
tell easy very easy guys I'm sorry I'm
very tall I'm very tall now it should
stand up straight and I think 3/4 of
this video is going to be opening things
what this is a vanilla extract that's
too much gonna peel ginger here so I'll
add some honey now there's a lot of
sweet stuff going in here I hope there's
enough I've never used this word before
but aromatic I like to let that word fly
every now and then now all I need to do
is bring this poached saw mixture to a
simmer got all sorts of little low
bubblies it's not quite boiling it's
just getting nice and warm all right
this almost looks like potpourri soup
which also is my Wi-Fi password
ultimately we're looking forward to get
tender so that we can plate it and make
it delicious
[Music]
all right everybody I don't know why
thank you it's been about 20 minutes
hair looks nice and relaxed
so as this pair is relaxing I'm thinking
about how to present it because it
really needs a good send-off
into my stomach it's come down to room
temperature so I'm gonna make some
little last-minute adjustments to it
we're gonna dress it up with some
toppings and we're gonna pair it
[Music]
okay I don't want to jump to any
conclusions but I think we're done and I
think it looks pretty good okay I'm
gonna show it to you in three two one
before I show anyone I think I should
just try it in case I whip it off and
someone's like hey can I try it and then
it's bad then I'll be devastated
it's great definitely very good I'm
gonna see what some other people think
so have you tried this new beautiful
hair I have tried it and I'm pleased
with myself I think I did a good job and
here's what it looks like now wow this
is beautiful you don't have is it's like
very aromatic that's exactly what I said
this is a glow up
[Music]
I'm feeling very emotional because I
just saw this right I just saw this pair
it was a no one wanted to buy it except
for you an asset for me
it sucked it was a tear I hated that
pair an hour ago I was like your [ __ ] I
can't believe how good it tasted how
beautiful it looks and I'm not even
exaggerating I don't know why I'm so
impressed with it and that's what I'm
talking about the next time you're in
the grocery store and you see a piece of
produce that is just a little rough
around the edges take it home give it a
second chance because you have no idea
what sort of potential is in that fruit
or vegetable
[Music]